Hãy xem qua bộ không ăn đã chỗ chỉ, với hợp với bộ nơi buồn, về nhanh lắm và phòng công nghệ Việt Nam,
cùng với các đơn vị trên 2 công tác thù nhật lối sánh phần tích và giám địa HDN.
Qua nói sách địa và công nhận giánh tiến cho 2 mila mẹ sĩ chưa sách địa được thực tình.
Chính dịch các điểm lần này, được phát động đồng rạc trên quy mô tần quốc,
kéo dài từ ngày 1,5 hãi, với một tiêu lấy 2,5 mili mẫu xin và mạc đen của thân dân các lệ sĩ.
Đây là một chiến dịch quy mô lớn, đoàn hỏi sự và cuộc đông bộ của cả hệ thông truy trị.
Chúng đỏ lực lượng không ăn nhân dân dữ vài cho nông cốt.
Lãnh đạo bộ công an đã rao cuộc khánh sách khoảng lý hành chính về trật tự sáng hội xe khẩu xa ổ chữ trách nhiệm hương dẫn.
Nôn đốc và chuẩn bị mọi điều kiện kiến thật để bảo đảm tính chính sách tốt đà trong quá trình cập nhật dữ liệu.
Để chiến dịch đặt hiệu quả cầu nhất, các bạn các tình thành phố đã chỉ đạo các phòng nghiệp vụ.
Vụ hợp chặt chẽ với lực lượng công an sả tiến hả khảo sách, sắc mình thông tin gì bến đồng của thân nhân lệ sĩ,
các phương an bộ chỉ máy móc, địa điểm thu mẫu lưu đầu và của định đang được hình trường hoàn thiệt.
Mà đảm sự thần tiện nhất trong người dân, nhưng vẫn tối hả quy trình bảo khoảng sinh phần,
phát biểu tại buổi lễ, họ thủ đứng phạm bị thích trang nhìn mạc.
Dìm nhấn đầy xúc độc tại buổi lễ là khoảng khác bộ công an chào khi quả sách nghiệp a đean.
Chính thức sân nhận dành tính cho năm lệ sĩ trước sự chứng kiến của các đại biểu, sau hàng trục năm khác khoảng đean.
Nhưng rồi, nước mắt hạnh phúc của các thân nhân đã mình chứng cho giả trị nhân văn phó lớn mặt chiến dịch mạng lại.
Ngay sò lệ phát động, các đại biểu đã chứng kiến hoàn đồng thu nhận mẫu xí phẩm a đean,
đối với thân nhân lệ sĩ trên đẹp bản thình của ha nội.
Phó nống thư vấn, chào tặng thuốc và các sản phẩm trong xóc suy khỏe cho thân nhân lệ sĩ của được tổ chức tại sự kiệt.